Lines spilled out into the street as fans
flocked to their nearest cinema to watch the
culmination of a decade of Marvel movies when
Avengers: Endgame finally arrived in theaters,
and judging from the reaction on Twitter,
the vast majority left more than happy.
Warning: Spoilers ahead!
Filmmaker and self-professed fanboy Kevin
Smith got to attend the Endgame world premiere
with his daughter, Harley Quinn Smith.
Yes, the man loves comics.
Unsurprisingly, the Mallrats director absolutely
loved the movie, and he was eager to share
that fact.
Taking to Twitter afterwards, Smith predicted
that Endgame was going to smash box office
records.
"3 hours later and I'm shook!
My God, Avengers: Endgame is beyond epic!
It's everything you hope it will be and more,
an absolute Marvel Studios marvel!
And I'm pretty sure it will make all the money
ever printed!
Loved it and would watch again instantly!"
The hype surrounding Avengers: Endgame was
so huge that it would have been considered
a disappointment if was anything short of
the best superhero movie ever made.
Fortunately for Marvel and everyone involved
with the picture, it was exactly that, at
least according to Emmy-nominated producer
and film critic Scott Mantz, who tweeted,
"INCREDIBLE!! brings the entire MCU to a rousing,
exciting, deeply moving and wholly satisfying
conclusion!
It's a *BEAUTIFUL* film!
Fun, smart, clever, BRILLIANT!
Perfect blend of action, heart and humor!
This is as good as it gets!
Greatest superhero movie EVER!"
With a runtime of three hours and one minute,
Marvel ran the risk of dragging out proceedings
somewhat, but if anything, three hours and
one minute wasn't enough.
The film hurtles by as loose ends are tied
and sacrifices are made, culminating in a
battle of truly epic proportions.
After the time-traveling Avengers finally
manage to bring the Infinity Stones back to
the present, Thanos arrives to wipe them and
the rest of humanity out for good.
One thing's for sure, the final act of the
movie really sticks with you.
YouTube star NoahJ456 tweeted,
"I can't stop thinking about it.
I think the last hour of Avengers: Endgame
was the greatest hour of film ever to be shown
on the big screen."
CinemaBlend events editor Eric Eisenberg describes
himself as a "film and comics obsessive" in
his Twitter bio, meaning he's the kind of
guy who's particularly hard to please when
it comes to superhero movies.
Judging from the tweet he sent out after seeing
Endgame for the first time, Marvel exceeded
expectations with this picture.
"This can't be understated: Avengers: Endgame
is everything you want it to be and more.
I am absolutely floored.
A perfect reflection on the last 11 years
that pays off everything in the best way possible.
Without question my new favorite Marvel Cinematic
Universe film.
Stunned."
Character limits mean nothing when you've
got a good meme.
Twitter users were in good form when Endgame
was released, with MCU fans using images and
movie clips to convey the emotions that their
words simply could not.
One user by the name of RIPeterParker posted
a screenshot of Chadwick Boseman's King T'Challa
visiting his father in the Ancestral Plane
and confessing that he's not ready to move
on without him.
With the image, they wrote,
"Me staying in my seat and refusing to leave
the cinema after the credits rolled because
I'm far too attached to these characters and
this story."
"I am not ready to be without you."
Other users have been poking fun at the fact
that Marvel has urged people not to spoil
the movie, posting what they're calling "spoilers
without context."
These range from beer bellies and rats to
cheeseburgers and tacos.
If you've seen Endgame by now, you get it.
The word "epic" is probably thrown around
a little too liberally in the world of pop
culture, and the word was used a lot on Twitter
following the premiere of Endgame.
Was this just fans doing what fans do and
going overly crazy over something they love,
or is Endgame truly epic?
According to novelist and veteran reporter
Anthony Breznican, it most certainly is.
In his estimation,
"Epic is the word.
Epic multiplied by a decade of emotion, excitement
and investment.
This is the payoff.
It left me with a full heart, but one I had
has some scars on it.
Those are the strongest kind, after all."
While many have been trolling Avengers fans
with wild and elaborate fake spoilers, some
people have broken the golden rule and revealed
big details from the movie on Twitter.
We're going to dive into those big spoilers
right now, so this is your last chance to
keep Endgame a secret if you haven't seen
it.
Matter of fact, you may do well to stay off
the Internet entirely, because charmingly
blunt tweets like this one are definitely
making the rounds:
"Iron man dies, Natasha Romanoff dies, Captain
America gets old (technically implied dead)
Thor is fat, Gamora is now alive and Loki
is also alive, Valkyrie is now the ruler of
Asgard, Thanos disappears.
Tony Stark has a daughter.
Bruce Banner and Hulk live as one so it's
smart Hulk."
And, yeah.
That pretty much sums the whole thing up.
It happened with Josh Brolin's Thanos after
Infinity War, but this time out, Mark Ruffalo's
Hulk was Twitter's bizarre crush.
Ruffalo has played Bruce Banner and the Hulk
for years now, so what's the big deal?
This time, they're one and the same, and the
result is giving some Twitter users confusing
feelings.
As one smitten fan tweeted,
"Hey not to be predictably me, but why is
Professor Hulk so hot?"
Another said that they were sticking to their
guns despite the critics, declaring,
"I'm being bullied for speaking my truth!
Yes, I'd smash Hulk!
He's the hot professor I've always wanted!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.